e adesso vi voglio parlare di come la
flessibilità l'equilibrio la sensibilità
e la resilienza siano roba da donne
guardate qui abbiamo comincerà questa
breve presentazione parlando di un po
della mia attività di ricerca
io mi occupo di dispositivi e sistemi
che sono implementati su substrati
flessibili
quindi questi sono materiali sistemi
intrinsecamente resilienti e vedete
perché qui abbiamo un video dove c'è un
normale schermo di un cellulare su vetro
che è chiaramente un sistema fragile e
qui invece guardate questo display
quali caratteristiche a prego di far
partire il video benissimo abbiamo un
martello che comincia a martellare ecco
che abbiamo rotto lo schermo fragile ed
ecco lo schermo flessibile
guardate in che maniera resiste a
sollecitazioni meccaniche veramente
eccezionali e guardate la qualità dello
schermo guardate la qualità
dell'immagine
bene questo è un prototipo di samsung
potete trovare questo video sul web
e questa è una tecnologia che noi usiamo
qual è la karate cordate potete piegarlo
potete potete fare quello che volete è
l'immagine è sempre quella e questa sarà
la tecnologia che darà luogo in futuro a
tutta una serie di prodotti di consumo
completamente diversi da quelli che
siamo abituati a vedere adesso cosa
facciamo noi
bene noi prendiamo questa tecnologia che
peraltro è anche implementabile a costi
bassi perché i grandi dispositivi
transistor e i circuiti possono essere
realizzati tramite un processo di stampa
invece che avere gli inchiostri colorati
abbiamo degli inchiostri che sono a base
di materiali organici semiconduttori
isolanti
metallici a conducibilità metallica bene
stampiamo sulla plastico addirittura
sulla carta questi circuiti e l'inter
facciamo con sistemi biologici
l'idea è quella di creare un sistema un
circuito con forma bile che si può per
esempio racchiudere nel quale si può
racchiudere un organo intero come il
cuore una sorta di pericardio
elettronico che sia in grado di
interagire con sistema biologico in
maniera bidirezionale informazioni o
meglio stimoli che dal circuito arrivano
al l'organo biologico è l'organo
biologico che invia informazioni al
circuito e diciamo una tecnologia
estremamente interessante della quale ci
occupiamo ma in realtà oggi vi volevo
parlare del sistema che probabilmente
più velocemente vedrà il mercato ed è
sempre l'utilizzo di questi sistemi
elettronici flessibili eventualmente
implementati anche su carta quindi a
basso costo usa e getta che possono
funzionare però come sensori
l'idea è la seguente noi abbiamo che
oggi anche al suo in farmacia o il
supermercato è possibile comprare degli
strip test che ci permettono di fare
un'analisi per esempio lo stato di
gravidanza piuttosto che diciamo
l'analisi glucometri ca
ecco però l'informazione che ci deriva
da questi streep usa e getta
un'informazione che è tipica di un
sistema analogico quindi è
un'informazione che in realtà ci dà
un'idea di massima di quale la nostra
situazione ma non può essere utilizzata
per farne una diagnostica
l'idea è quella di utilizzare i nostri
sistemi che sono dei sistemi che danno
la possibilità di avere un output
digitale e la qualità del dato che è
fornita è estremamente elevata e possono
essere utilizzati naturalmente per una
diagnostica direttamente per una
diagnostica by passando per esempio la
fase del laboratorio di analisi
chiaramente questo ha il potenziale di
rivoluzionare il nostro approccio alla
diagnostica e anche nei paesi in via di
sviluppo darà la possibilità di fornire
questi streep a basso costo e una volta
effettuata all'analisi anche attraverso
sistemi per esempio wireless
l'informazione potrà essere
immediatamente disponibile per
effettuare delle delle diagnosi e quindi
chiaramente sarà un sistema estremamente
economico interessante per per molti
aspetti
quindi abbiamo visto come questi siano
sistemi resilienti non solo dal punto di
vista delle loro proprietà meccaniche ma
per esempio anche dal punto di vista
della capacità di interagire con un
sistema o un ambito biologico un
dispositivo elettronico che sia
resiliente in un ambito biologico non è
banale da immaginare e questa è la
strada sulla quale noi ci stiamo
ci siamo incamminati ormai da tempo
adesso vorrei cambiare leggermente
registro e vorrei affrontare il tema
della equilibrio di genere e della
resilienza
qual è il punto nell'immaginario
collettivo e di molti la ed era anche la
mia percezione fino a qualche tempo fa
che ormai le donne siano ovunque abbiano
ormai una posizione
diciamo di parità nella società civile
bene vi mostrerò delle statistiche
quindi dei numeri che ci fotografano una
situazione molto diversa da quella che è
la percezione dei più per fare questo
farò ricorso ad un documento che si
chiama i tigres e che raccoglie tutte le
statistiche tutti i dati di tutte le
università europee e li divide diciamo
mettendo in evidenza il rapporto in
termini di numerosità e quindi di
percentuali fra le donne e gli uomini e
questo documento è disponibile anche
grazie a marie gauguin queen che è uno
dei direttori generali generali della
ricerca e innovazione della commissione
europea
questi sono i numeri vediamo un attimo
brevemente di che cosa si tratta
abbiamo nell'asse delle ascisse
purtroppo è stato tagliato va bene
abbiamo le varie fasi della progressione
di carriera dell'accademia allora queste
sono le studentesse appena iscritti agli
studenti appena iscritti all'università
questi sono i laureati questi sono gli
studenti di dottorato
questi sono i laureati dottorandi
dottorati dottorandi e queste sono i
ricercatori professori associati e i
professori ordinari
la linea viola e la linea delle donne la
linea arancione è la linea degli uomini
è abbastanza e questi sono i dati
immediati su tutta l'accademia europea
quindi che cosa abbiamo abbiamo che le
donne si scrivono è solo il 55 per cento
e questi dati sono al 2010 che sono gli
ultimi disponibili le linee più scure
sono i dati del 2010
bene le studentesse sono il 55 per cento
gli studenti sono il 46 per cento
crescono leggermente quando si la rona
addirittura abbiamo il 59 per cento
delle studentesse che si laureano e poi
questa linea inesorabilmente decresce e
quando arriviamo ai professori ordinari
abbiamo che il 20 per cento della
popolazione dei professori ordinari e
donna
non parliamo di rettori non parliamo di
direttori generali parliamo di
professori ordinari per gli uomini che
cosa succede
il 46 per cento degli uomini sono
studenti si laureano il 42 per cento
e poi inesorabilmente si incamminano
lungo una strada che li porterà a
diventare professori ordinari in ragione
dell 80 per cento nel 2010
le linee più chiare di questo grafico
sono invece i dati relativi al 2002
se fate il confronto dal 2002 al 2010
passiamo dalle 15 per cento al 20 per
cento di donne
sembrerebbe una velocità una reit
piuttosto elevata ma vi dico che nel
mezzo ci sono i dati del 2006
scusatemi del 2002 scusate del 2006 che
portano il 20 per cento quindi dal 2006
al 2010 il numero di donne o professore
ordinario non è aumentato
questo è tutta l'accademia quindi
parliamo sia delle diciamo scienze
umanitarie che della parte più
prettamente scientifica se invece
restringiamo lì insieme alle sole
discipline tecnico scientifiche e vero
che le studentesse sono di meno ma il
numero di professori ordinari donne cala
all 11 per cento
una volta presenta di solito quando
presento questi dati la domanda che mi
viene fatta è va bene il 2010 siamo già
nel 2015 il processo sta andando avanti
abbiamo cominciato molto a rilento ma
adesso stiamo siamo prendiamo
guadagnando terreno molto bene
ecco questa e dividiamo la risposta che
ci da rossella palomba in un suo
bellissimo libro che si chiama sognando
parità le cifre ha fatto delle
proiezioni basandosi sui dati
che vi ho mostrato affatto delle
proiezioni e ha cercato di capire entro
quanto tempo la reazione di riequilibrio
di tra uomini e donne nelle posizioni
apicali avrà termine
e questi sono i dati se noi manteniamo
lo status quo delle cose quindi di
questo passo la parità fra dirigenti e
uomini e donne nei ministeri si avrà nel
37 ci vogliono 22 anni
nell'università ce ne vogliono 37 nella
70 nella sanità 72
se vogliamo invece la parità tra
professori ordinari quella ce l'avremo
fra 125 anni se invece la vogliamo nella
pubblica amministrazione consigli di
amministrazione perdonatemi quindi nel
privato 128 anni abbiamo il diritto di
voto da 70 anni mi sembra diciamo che la
scala dei tempi sia decisamente troppo
ampia ciò nonostante il fatto che il 71
per cento delle diplomate frequenta
l'università contro il 60 per cento dei
maschi il 70 per cento degli iscritti
alle scuole di specializzazione e donna
il 25 per cento delle ragazze va a
teatro contro il 20 per cento dei
ragazzi e il 64 per cento delle delle
giovani donne leggono libri di più del
40 per cento dei ragazzi e visitano più
mostre quindi abbiamo un problema chiaro
di scollamento fra impegno e diciamo
attività e assegnazione di compiti di
responsabilità e questo badate bene è un
problema di negazione del merito da
tempi ancestrali
per quale motivo molto semplice se io un
campione di 100 persone 50 uomini e 50
donne e comincia a prendere da questo
campione un uomo lo metto in posizione
apicale una donna la metto in posizione
apicale continuo
ma a un certo punto per uno strano
motivo arrivata al 15 20 per cento
mi fermo non prendo più donne e continua
a prendere uomini ci sarà una
percentuale di uomini che ricoprirà
posizioni apicali che ha qualità
inferiori rispetto al corrispondente
percentuale di donne che ho lasciato a
casa addirittura naturalmente perché le
posizioni apicali sono importanti le
posizioni apicali sono importanti perché
noi abbiamo noi il nostro diciamo
processo cognitivo passa attraverso
l'emulazione e se le ragazze non trovano
donne nelle posizioni apicali a cui
rifarsi come modelli di ruolo non
ambiranno a quelle posizioni le
considereranno fuori dalla loro
ricezione dalla loro penseranno di non
poterci arrivare quindi diventa
fondamentale che queste
dati diventino il più possibile pubblici
e pubblicizzati ed è un problema
economico perché noi evidentemente non
solo perché come dice appunto christine
lagarde quando le donne vanno meglio
l'economia va meglio ma perché noi
abbiamo spendiamo gual danaro pubblico
per formare le donne e gli uomini e una
parte dei cervelli che formiamo li
lasciamo a casa e quindi è fondamentale
che questo non accada è molto
velocemente vorrei darvi una e quindi
diciamo la resilienza delle donne che
oggi arriva in posizione apicale è
particolarmente rilevante e molto
velocemente vi vorrei fare il caso di
una storia di resilienza di una donna di
scienza di resilienza il nobel per la
medicina fu dato a creek watch phone e
wilkins nel 62 grazie alla scoperta
della struttura a doppia elica del dna
cioè delle basi dello reed delle basi
della vita questa fotografia che è in
realtà una crystal un'analisi cristallo
grafica del dna è stata la prima
evidenza sperimentale che il dna aveva
una struttura a doppia elica bene questa
fotografia l'ha fatta rosalind franklin
come vedete non è nominata fra quelli
che hanno preso il nobel per questa
scoperta come molte delle cose diciamo
nella scienza e nelle attività umane
ovviamente a delle zone d ombra ma tutti
concordano nel dire che questa giovane
scienziata arrivata al king's college di
londra negli anni 50 sia stata accolta
da wilkins con il quale avrebbe dovuto
collaborare assumendo immediatamente
senza neanche discuterle che lei era
l'assistente di wilkins lei non si
sentiva l'assistente di nessuno riteneva
di poter contribuire autonomamente
all'attività di ricerca come ha
dimostrato
e stata praticamente diciamo lasciata in
un angolo i tre uomini si sono invece
accordati organizzati e di fatto hanno
preso il premio nobel lei non l'ha presa
anche perché poi poveretta nel frattempo
è anche deceduta probabilmente a causa
delle radiazioni hicks e diciamo il
fatto che lei si sia sentita un
pochettino discriminata
magari potrebbe suonarci veritiero dal
momento che poi wilkins più in là negli
anni è stato diciamo tacciato di aver
fatto delle dichiarazioni decisamente
poco diciamo
politicamente corrette e quindi
probabilmente ha detto che le persone di
colore erano meno intelligenti e di
quelle non di colore quindi diciamo
probabilmente qualche tendenza alla
discriminazione ce l'aveva e anche
ammesso vabbè all'asta la sua medaglia
del nobel
quindi direi che rosalind a più di una
volta detto immagino che abbia più di
una volta ha detto kim keep calm and be
resilient grazie per l'attenzione